I'm shaking Bart's and when I get my
name I'm often asked were you from and I
normally say London but of course um I
know what they're really asking so I say
something like well my grandparents and
my mum were born in India my dad and I
were born in Kenya and I was brought up
in London and then they've got me mapped
ah you're a Kenyan Asian I've worked
with one of those for my name they
probably assume that I'm a Hindu and
this sort of fixes me for them but what
about the Christians and the Muslims and
the atheists that I grew up with or the
Socialists and the Liberals even the
occasional Tory indeed all kinds of
women and men vegetable sellers factory
workers cooks car mechanics living in my
working-class area in some profoundly
important way they are also a part of me
and are here with me maybe that's why I
find it hard to respond to questions
about identity and about origin and it's
not just a sort of teenage refusal to be
labeled
it's about our own most identities the
ones that we put our hands up to the
ones that we cheer for the ones that we
fight for the ones that we love or hate
and it's about how we apprehend
ourselves as well as others and it's
part identities we just assumed that we
have without thinking too much about
them but our responses to questions of
identity and origin have substantial
social and political importance we see
the wars the rages of identity going on
all around us receive violent religious
national and ethnic disputes and often
the conflict is based on old stories of
identity and belonging and origins and
these identities are based on myths
typically about ancient primordial
origins and these could be about Adam
and Eve or by the supremacy of a caste
or gender or about the vitality of a
supposed race or about the past glories
of an empire or civilization or at a
piece of land that some imagined deity
has gifted now people say that origin
stories and identity mists make us feel
secure what's wrong with that they give
us a sense of belonging identities your
cultural clothing and it can make you
feel warm and fuzzy inside but does it
really do we really need identity myths
to feel safe because I see religious
national ethnic disputes as adding to
human misery can I dare you to refuse
every origin myth that claims you what
if we reject every single primordial
origin myth and develop a deeper sense
of personhood one responsible to
humanity as a whole rather than to a
particular tribe a radically different
idea of humanity that exposes how origin
myths mystify disguise global power
rapacious exploitation poverty the
worldwide oppression of women and girls
and of course massive accelerating
inequalities now origin myths are
closely linked to tradition and the word
tradition points to something old and
permanent almost natural and people
assume tradition is just history simply
the past condensed into a nice story but
let's not confuse tradition with history
the two are often in severe conflict
origin stories they usually recently
created fictions of ancient belonging
and their absurd given the complexity of
humanity and our vastly interconnected
even if very unequal world and today we
see claims to tradition that claim to be
ancient changing rapidly in front of our
eyes as water
the 1970s near Wembley with Asian
English Caribbean Irish families
industry in our street living in our
streets and the neo-nazi National Front
was massive then with regular marches
and attacks on us and a permanent threat
and often a frequent reality of violence
against us on the streets in our homes
typically by neo-nazis and other racists
and I remember during a general election
a leaflet came through our letter box
with a picture of the National Front
candidate for our area
and the picture was of our next-door
neighbor he threatened to shoot me once
when I played in the garden as a kid a
many weekend shaven-headed Marshall from
activists arrived at his house and
emerged with scores of placards
screaming that they wanted us to go back
home but today is one of my mom's best
mates it's a very lovely gentle and kind
man and at some point in his political
journey out of fascism he embraced a
broader idea of humanity there was a
Hindu family that we got to know well
and you have to understand that life in
our street was a little bit like the
setting for an Asian soap opera everyone
knew everyone else's business even if
they didn't want it to be known by
anyone at all you really had no choice
in this matter within this family there
was a quiet little boy who went to the
same school as I did and after I left
school I didn't hear much more about him
except that he'd gone off to India now
around 2000 I remember seeing this short
book the book was unusual because it was
written by a British supporter of
al-qaeda and in it the author calls for
attacks in Britain this is in 1999 so
9/11 and the invasion of Iraq were still
in the future and he helped Scout New
York bombing targets he taught others
how to make a dirty bomb Jews on the
London Underground and he plotted a
massive bombing campaign in London's
shopping areas it's a very high-risk
security prisoner in the UK and one of
the most important
I'll try the figures to be arrested in
Britain the author of that book was a
very same quiet little boy who went to
my school so a Hindu boy from Britain
became an al-qaeda fighter and a
most-wanted international terrorist and
he rejected what people call his Hindu
or Indian or British identity and he
became someone else he refused to be who
he was he recreated himself and this
kind of journey is very common for young
men and women who become involved in
al-qaeda or Islamic state or other
transnational armed groups al-qaeda's
media spokesman is a white American from
a Jewish and Catholic mixed background
and neither he nor the boy from my
school were from Muslim backgrounds
there's no point asking them where are
they from a more important question is
where they're going and I would also put
it to you that exactly the same journey
occurs for those young men and women who
were brought up in Muslim family
backgrounds most of those who join
al-qaeda and other Salafi jihadi groups
from Europe Asia North America even in
many cases the Middle East are those who
have comprehensively rejected their
backgrounds to become in essence new
people they spend an enormous amount of
time attacking their parents backgrounds
as profane impure blasphemous the wrong
type of Islam and their vision instead
is a fantastical view of cosmic
apocalypse
it's a born again vision discard your
past your society your family and
friends since they're all impure instead
become someone else your true self your
authentic self
now this isn't about a return to the
past it's about using a forgery of the
past to envision an appalling future
which begins today at year 0 this is why
over 80 percent of the victims of
al-qaeda in Islamic state are people
from Muslim backgrounds
first act by Salafi jihadi groups when
they take over an area is to destroy
existing Muslim institutions including
mosques shrines preachers practices the
main purpose is to control and punish
people internally to dictate the spaces
that women may go their clothing family
relations beliefs even the minut detail
of how one prays and you get the
impression in the news that they are
after us in the West but they are
actually mainly after people from other
Muslim backgrounds in their view no
other Muslim can ever be pure enough so
ordinary beliefs and practices that have
existed for centuries are attacked as
impure by teenagers from Birmingham or
London who know nothing about the
histories that they so joyously
obliterate now here their claim to
tradition is at war with history but
they're nevertheless very certain about
their purity and about the impurity of
others purity certainty the return to
authentic tradition the quest for these
can lead to lethal visions of perfect
societies and perfected people this is
what the main Hindu fundamentalist
organization in India looks like today
at its mass rally maybe it reminds you
of the 1930s in Italy or Germany and the
movements roots are indeed in fascism it
was a member of this same Hindu
fundamentalist movement who shot dead
Mahatma Gandhi Hindi fundamentalists
today view this murderer as a national
hero and they want to put up statues of
him throughout India they've been
involved for decades in large-scale mass
violence against minorities they banned
books art films they attack romantic
couples on Valentine's Day Christians on
Christmas Day they don't like others
talking critically about what they see
as their ancient culture or using its
images or Parekh assuring it
or drawing cartoons about it but the
people making the strongest possible
claims about ancient timeless Hindu
religion are dressed in brown shorts and
white shirts while claiming oddly to be
the original Aryan race just like the
violent Salafi jihadi z-- who make their
claims about their primordial religion
while dressed in black military uniforms
and wearing balaclavas these people are
manufacturing pure pristine identities
of conviction and of certainty
fundamentalists see religion and culture
as their sole property a property but
religions and cultures are processes
they're not things they're impermanent
they're messy they're impure look at any
religion and you'll see disputes and
arguments going all the way down any
criticism of religion in any form has to
therefore be part of the expansive sense
of humanity we should aspire to I
respect your right to have and to
express your religion or your culture or
your opinion but I don't necessarily
have to respect the content I might like
some of it and I'd like how an old
church looks for example but this isn't
the same thing
similarly I have a human right to say
something that you may find offensive
but you do not have a human right not to
be offended in a genuine democracy we're
constantly offended since people express
different views all the time they also
change their views so they've used our
impermanent you cannot fix someone's
political views based on their religious
or national or cultural background now
these points about religious purity also
apply to nationalism and to racism I'm
always puzzled to have pride in your
national or ethnic identity pride in the
accident of birth from a woman CAHSEE
womb belief in your superiority because
of the accident of birth these people
have very firm ideas about what belongs
and what doesn't belong inside the cozy
national cultures that they imagine and
I'm going to caricature a bit here but
only a little bit I want you to imagine
the supporter of some little Englander
or British nationalist political party
and he's sitting at home and he's
screaming about foreigners invading his
country while watching Fox News American
cable channel owned by an Australian on
his South Korean television set which
was brought by his Spanish credit card
which has paid off monthly by his high
street British bank which has its
headquarters in Hong Kong he supports a
British football team owned by a Russian
his favourite brand of fish and chips is
done by Swedish venture capitalist firm
the church he sometimes goes to has its
Creed decided in meetings in Ghana his
Union Jack Underpants were made in India
thank you and their and their laundered
regularly by a very nice polish lady
there is no pure ethnicity national
culture and the ethical choices we have
today a far wider than being having them
being forced to choose between racist
right and religious right visions dismal
visions of culture now culture isn't
just about language food clothing and
music but gender relations ancient
monuments a heritage of sacred texts but
culture can also be what has been
decided to be culture by those who have
a political stake in pounding culture
into the shape of a prison big political
identity claims our elite bid for power
they're not answers to social or
economic or political in justices they
often obscure them and what about the
large number of people across the globe
who can point to monument from their
past who don't possess a sacred written
text who can't hark back to the past
glories of a civilization or Empire are
these people lesser parts of humanity
what about you now listening to this
what about you and your identity because
you stitch your experiences and your
thoughts into a continuous person moving
forward in time and this is what you are
when you say I am or me but this will
also include all of your hopes and
dreams all of the use that could have
been and it includes all the other
people and the things that are in the
biography of who you are they the others
are also a part of you moving forward
with you your authentic self if such a
thing exists is a complex messy and
uncertain self and that is a very good
thing why not value those impurities and
uncertainties maybe clinging to pure
identities is a sign of a maturity and
ethnic nationalist and religious
traditions of
for you why not be skeptical about every
primordial origin claim made on your
behalf
why not reject the identity myths that
call on you to belong that politicians
and community leaders so-called
community leaders place on you if we
don't need origin stories and fixed
identities we can challenge ourselves to
think creatively about each other and
our future and here culture always takes
care of itself I'm not worried about
culture culture cultures a creative
dynamic processes not imposed laws and
boundaries this is a bull wallet
Mohammed eben Ahmed even rushed a very
senior Muslim judge and thinker in
Cordoba in the 12th century and his
writings were considered deeply
blasphemous heretical and evil long
after he died followers of his work were
ruthlessly hunted down banished and
killed over several centuries by the
most powerful religious institution of
the medieval period that institution was
the Roman Catholic Church why because it
been rushed said there's something true
in religion may conflict with something
that your reason finds to be true on
earth but the latter is still true there
are two distinct worlds of truth one
based on our reason and evidence and one
that is divine and the state political
power social law are in the realm of
reason religious life is a different
realm they should be kept separated
social and political life should be
governed by our reason not by religion
and you can see why the church was upset
by his writings as indeed were some
Muslims during his lifetime because he
gives us a strong statement of
secularism of a kind which is normally
in Europe today now history plays many
tricks on us it undermines our fixed
truths and what we believe to be our
culture and their culture it be
nourished someone who happens to be a
Muslim is considered one of the key
influences in the introduction and
spread of secularism and Europe so
against religious nationalist and racial
purists of all kinds can
you make his story a part of your own
not because he happened to be a Muslim
not because he happened to be an Arab
but because he was a human being with
some very good ideas that shook his
world and ours thank you
[Applause]